I think our draft class might have been  like one of the best hardest draft  classes you know you my dog man and I  love you man but 2011 Draft class was  crazy bro Cam Newton me Patrick Peterson  Marshall dearest DJ why Ron Smith  Richard Sherman Justin Houston I think  we're going to compete though  nah like no  no why I don't look at Waddles during  this year with Tariq on the team certain  what he's doing Sean Slater Sean  Slater's hard I love her I love her  shots Sean said it's hard J.C horn Kyle  Pitts I can't forget Kyle Fields look at  what Phil's doing now you're right  you're right I wouldn't say you right  but it's you you have a great great  argument